the Senate would not be a good place for
you and at a time when many Americans
are not optimistic about our country's
future what would you want those
teachers to tell their students about
their future in this country well look I
think because of our woeful ignorance of
American history we always think the
current period we're in is tougher than
others we've had nothing like the Civil
War period we haven't had a single
instance where a congressman from South
Carolina came over and almost beat to
death a senator from Massachusetts
America's had plenty of tough challenges
world wars depressions this is a great
country you know we're gonna deal with
whatever our current problems are and
move on to another level and I'm just as
optimistic as I ever was that this
generation is going to leave behind a
better America
than our parents left behind for us well
that's an optimistic message from a kid
who had polio overcame it set his sights
to be in the United States Senate made
it and became the majority leader after
about 50 years of keeping his eye on the
ball Chet Atkins the nashville guitarist
used to say in this life you have to be
mighty careful where you aim because
you're likely to get there and senator
Mitch McConnell did thank you very much
for talking with me thank you long
see spam created by America's cable
television companies and brought to you
as a public service by your cable or
satellite provider
and starting now day two book TVs live
coverage of the printers roll it fest in
Chicago the festival in its 32nd year
features both local and national authors
many of whom you'll hear from today on
both TV you'll hear from Sidney
Blumenthal Sebastian Junger
Natalie more on segregation in Chicago
and across America and many others for a
complete schedule check out our web site
book TV org or follow us on twitter at
book TV or on facebook facebook.com
slash book TV now we're going to kick
off today's coverage with Bradley bursar
talking about the philosopher Russell
Kirk this is live coverage on book TV on
c-span too
welcome to the 32nd annual Chicago
Tribune printers roll lit best I want to
give a special thank you to all our
sponsors the theme of this year's
festival is what's your story we and we
encourage you to share the stories you
hear this weekend on Twitter Instagram
or Facebook using hashtag PRL f/16 you
can keep the spirit of lit fest going
all year by downloading the printers ro
app where you'll find all of the Chicago
Tribune's premium books content free and
discounted ebooks for subscribers and
the complete printers roll it best
schedule download today to get a free
ebook and five dollars off with best
merchandise today's program will be
broadcast live on c-span choose book TV
if there's time at the end for a Q&A
session with the author we ask you to
use the microphone located to your right
so that the home viewing audience can
hear your question before we begin
today's program we ask that you silence
your cellphone's and turn off your
camera flashes please welcome editor and
general manager of Tribune content
agency and today's interviewer john
baron
good morning everybody I love the smell
of books in the morning and it's it's
great to be around a bunch of friends
who feel the same way it's my pleasure
to help kick off today's today's day of
of lit fest and it's it's my great
pleasure to welcome Bradley J bursar who
is the author of Russell Kirk American
conservative Bradley is the russell amos
kirk chair in american studies and a
professor of history at Hillsdale
College he he came over this morning
from South Central Michigan made the
journey and is here to talk about his
his book about Russell Kirk and and one
of the first questions I guess for for
lots of people is is who is Russell Kirk
the man undoubtedly cast a very large
shadow over American political and
intellectual thought in the latter half
of the 20th century and it could be
argued that he still does yet Russell
Kirk's is not a name that is much known
these days or much less invoked these
days Brad your book does many many
things but it also helps serve as a
marvelous embracing introduction or
reintroduction to Russell Kirk we're
gonna talk about many things here today
but for starters please give us a quick
overview of this man and his importance
sure thank you John and thank you
everybody for coming here on a Sunday
morning it's a great pleasure to be here
and thanks to to c-span and book TV
Russell Kirk was born in 1918 in
Plymouth Michigan born into extreme
poverty and it was something that he
experienced during really the first 35
years of his life to varying degrees and
yet he was always very bookish became
interested in all kinds of things you
know if the stories are to be believed
he had read the collected works of Karl
Marx as well as Thomas Jefferson by
about the time he was 11 certainly he'd
read all of James Fenimore Cooper and
there's no doubt there was a certain
genius to this very very unusual young
man in Plymouth he ended up going to
Michigan State
afterwards he served in
military for about five years during
World War two when he came back from his
military experience he ended up getting
his graduate degree his deal it was a
little bit higher than a PhD but he got
his deal it at a Scottish University the
University of st. Andrews earned that
1952 came back in 1953 and strangely
enough his dissertation became this
million copy bestseller this book called
the conservative mind which the timing
was just right it hit the market from a
chicago publisher Regnery published it
on may 11th of 1953 ended up going
through seven editions over its lifetime
and it really did give there were a
number of disparate voices that I would
just say we're not leftist they might be
conservative to some degree libertarian
to another degree but there were a whole
number of voices that I think Kirk's
book allowed lynz it allowed something
some kind of forum for all of these
voices to be able to speak right at the
end of World War two right at the end of
the Korean War and so he becomes very
important especially we would never have
had a Barry Goldwater movement without
Kirk we also wouldn't have had a Reagan
movement later on without Kirk he did
represent that strain of conservatism
well and and he helped coalesce
conservative thought and and what's
what's interesting and what most people
might not imagine is that the milieu in
which the conservative mind came out in
1953 was very different and then then
the way we kind of offer a shorthand for
political thought at this point you know
we think about conservative and liberal
and we talk of we think about these
these things on the on the opposite
extremes we have pretty entrenched ideas
about what those terms mean they're
convenient shorthand at this point that
often lead to stereotypes but at the
time the conservative mind came out the
conservative conservative in really
wasn't a thing in in America that's
right and part of what Kirk had to do
was he had to bring together all of
these disparate story
and to give it some kind of coherence so
what he decided to do in his
dissertation and he never would he wrote
the dissertation he had certainly long
to be a well published author he never
anticipated that he would have the kind
of success that he did the timing was
perfect and he was a good writer a very
good writer he's an amazing stylist and
a good thinker as well but he certainly
didn't project okay this is gonna change
the world but even though and I think
you're absolutely right John that we've
kind of forgotten him in this day and
age forum about 1953 until 64 and once
once Goldwater fails and that of just
horrific failure in the 1964
presidential election Kirk's fortunes go
down as well and it really will take the
rest of his life he has 30 more years to
live after that he dies in 1994 it takes
him those 30 years to kind of rebuild
his reputation back to where it was
before the Goldwater debacle but when
you say and I think this has to be
stress and it can't be stressed enough
that Kirk's conservatism was not
political I think that is fundamental to
understanding the original conservative
movement it became political with the
Goldwater movement but when Kirk writes
the conservative mind he's not thinking
in terms of a political movement these
aren't youth for Reagan that's he's not
thinking the large defense and free
markets he's in favor of all of that but
his main idea of conservatism is really
presenting a kind of Western face
against the Soviets so it wasn't just
that we weren't Soviet or we were
anti-communist
but he actually wanted to try and figure
out a way that we were something that
was its own thing and yet he didn't want
to be ideological either so a lot of his
conservatism is very poetic it's very
literary it has to deal with arts
probably more than it has to do with tax
subsidies or military policy well and
and you know again to set the stage pre
1953 you think about conservatives not
really having a place at the table they
did they weren't you know really a firm
cemented
part of the spectrum with a with a
definition behind them keep in mind the
country is coming out of the Great
Depression the country has been
experiencing the New Deal for for quite
a while
you've got radical ideologies
germinating abroad you've got a giant
war that had taken place abroad there
was probably a general feeling that that
government control in in in ways bigger
than ever before was perhaps a little
bit necessary and that modernism was the
inevitable path for mankind then along
comes Kirk who presents a different path
yes and very anti-modern sees very leery
of this one of the things I think we
often forget and John your question
leads beautifully into this is that
modern conservatism really comes out of
two impulses number one it comes out of
the fear that there is a
collectivization going on not just in
governments so there's no doubt that
conservatives from the beginning we're
fearful of big government whether it was
you know what we see radically abroad
and the kind of terrorist ideological
regimes that we see in Russia and
Germany and Italy and Portugal and other
places prior to World War two and then
we see them in some ways decline during
World War two and other as we see them
increase it wasn't just a fear of that
abroad it was also fear that at home
through what we call progressivism that
there was a desire to solve all problems
through colossal institutions whether it
was GM which Kirk had no love for
whether it was educational bureaucracies
say Michigan State which again Kirk was
very fearful of these huge universities
or whether it was government so he was
as fearful of what he called the cult of
the colossal around anything that seemed
to be anti humane that was one of the
impulses that I think was very important
for all conservatism and libertarianism
at that time in the 1950s but the other
impulse which again we've forgotten and
we've even seen modern conservatives
I'll put them in quotes scare quotes but
we've even seen modern conservatives
lambaste this and this was a defense of
the traditional liberal arts
people like Russell Kirk Robert Nesbitt
William F Buckley they believed very
very strongly that our true voice was
the voice of Socrates and Plato and
Cicero and Agustin and they saw that
long line and they believed and I think
probably correctly that these things
were being attacked and it makes sense
just I don't think we have to be
conspiratorial here if national
governments get involved in funding
universities they're gonna want things
like science which science is great but
they're gonna use science for making
larger bombs and so the to kind of round
this question out John and hopefully one
of the things one of the things that is
tied to both the fear of what's colossal
as well as the loss of the Liberal Arts
is that we're pursuing power without
virtue and Kirk was absolutely horrified
and in the book I try to I'm not sure
how well I explained it but I try to
explain Kirk's feelings about this
he was horrified about the dropping of
the atomic bombs on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki I think this one those two
events right one event put together but
that dropping of the bomb first of all
the development of the bomb that
physicist would even consider this thing
I think he was just if this was too much
for him and I go into this in detail and
I hope people don't take Kirk as crazy
he saw this as a stoic old very old
stoic response kind of response that a
Marcus Aurelius might give but he
actually wondered as a member of the US
military if it was his duty to commit
suicide not because he was depressed not
because he was suicidal but because our
honor as Americans had been so tainted
by the attack on these cities that maybe
it was the duty of a good American to
actually have recompense to pay for this
in a kind of purgatory way very
interesting him obviously didn't commit
suicide but his letters and his diaries
at the time is just horrified by this
and you know I wanted to talk a little
bit more detail about Kirk's brand of
conservatism when we think of liberals
or conservatives these days we almost
can't help but fall into the trap of
of stereotype in in caricature we see
almost the cartoonish pop conservative
or conservatism or liberalism on on
radio and TV
you write that conservatism for Kirk was
served as a means a mood and an attitude
to conserve to preserve and to pass on
to future generations the best of the
humane tradition rather than to advocate
a particular political philosophy party
or agenda very different than than our
shorthand personally serve it is Emre
now could you talk a little bit about
what what what was his brand of
conservatism and why it's set
lots of mines on fire well as you said
so well just a few minutes ago John you
know it was not there were not many
conservative voices and they were not
unified by any means you had maybe
someone like Robert in his bed out it at
Berkeley you had people like Leo Strauss
here in Chicago you had Kirk and a lot
of these people were not coming out of
the Ivy League's which is interesting to
a lot of these people were people who
had been educated in smaller schools
there's a bit I don't want to take this
too far me Buckley obviously comes out
of the Ivy's but there is a bit of
animosity towards not only corporate
America but towards East Coast elitism
and the Ivy's as well that's coming out
of a lot of these people's I don't want
to suggest that that was a prime motive
factor but they were pretty proud that
they could get if yo jab the
institution's on the East Coast as well
but that conservatism as Kirk so the
word conservative is first used in the
American tradition in the modern sense
by a person out at one of the seven
sister schools a philosopher by the name
of Peter Viereck and he uses that in an
article in the Atlantic and you wouldn't
get from reading this that it's
political he's really talking about TS
Eliot and remembering the great things
in music and opera and so forth it's not
conservative in a political sense it's
not until after World War two that that
term starts getting banned tittered
around and so Kirk you again whether
he's right or wrong about this it's
really Kirk that does give that label
some kind of gravitas
some kind of real strength and it's not
a rallying cry for a party because
Eisenhower it takes him a while for
example to call himself that robert taft
takes it on pretty quickly but of course
he passes away in 1953 and you start
seeing it with National Review and
others but really for Kirk that
conservatism he gives us six canons in
the book the conservative mind which
defines it and those canons and he uses
the term Canon intentionally he's
actually a kind of a quasi atheist at
this point he'll convert to Roman
Catholicism but not until August of 1964
this is a very long journey for him and
he's 45 on the edge of 46 when he
converts to Catholicism he's really kind
of an atheist agnostic for most of his
life up to that point and yet if you
read those canons in 1953 they sound
deeply religious because they start off
by arguing we should believe in a in a
higher power we should believe in the
author of the natural law we should
believe in the dignity of every human
person he actually in his second tenant
he actually our canon actually sounds
like Vatican 2 I mean what he's saying
in 1953 could have easily been written
by someone in Rome during 1952 1962 in
1965 during the Vatican two council it's
all personal ISM it's all very humane in
the way that he's thinking about this
but I stress and I think it's important
to note that he uses the term Canon
because that meant a truth that wasn't
easily defined and so he is trying to
avoid a kind of Marxian program or a
fascistic conception of the state
he doesn't want conservatism to be an
ideology he doesn't want it to be a
party platform it's a way of thinking
and that way of thinking is kind of a
what we might call a stoic almost
agnostic Judaism or Christianity it's
good enough to have the ethics of
Socrates really to have this as a way of
moving forward and that's yeah we know
the history of conservatism of course
from its beginning is very Catholic and
very Jewish it's not proud
really until you have the revival of the
new right in the early 1970s so the
great movement is kind of it has those
religious overtones but it's not
blatantly religious in the way we'll
think of it with Jerry Falwell or Oral
Roberts or Pat Robertson later on so the
he puts out the conservative mind in
1953 it shows that there is not only
this this other point of view but that
it also has this very proud Anglo
American heritage that stretches back
couple of centuries and he instantly
became the spokesman for really what
became a movement what what did the book
accomplish and what was the reaction
it's still obviously in print at this
point it is very heady stuff it is not
your typical bestseller material and yet
that's what it became that's right it
went through seven editions during his
lifetime the last edition was published
in 1986 just about eight years before he
passed away
and he even says at the beginning most
likely this will be the last revision
the revisions do matter this is not just
a change of a name here there in
particular each edition changes the last
chapter so that it kind of looks forward
what is happening what is not the
original title interestingly enough was
called the Conservatives route because
Kirk thought that all conservatism would
be a rearguard action that there he
couldn't imagine anyone actually
stepping forth and using this as a way
to move into the future it would always
be a way of stopping radical
progressives holding them back to a
certain degree but he thought we would
lose and that that was not a typical
Whittaker Whittaker Chambers of course
even though he leaves communism is
always convinced that communism will win
he's joined the losing side but Henry
Regnery this publisher here in Chicago
which we identify usually with
conservatism he actually had made his
money by translating Catholic theology
in the late 1940s into English so a lot
of German scholars and a lot of French
scholars people like Gabriel Marcel
Rahman are Gordini he had translated
those and made his money that way
for he became known as conservatism but
when Kirk publishes this book it is in
the english-speaking world the
conservative mind is published in every
major periodical every major newspaper
several newspapers review it twice
because it becomes so big that they feel
like they have to go back and look at it
again and make sure they didn't get it
wrong almost everybody is laudatory you
find a few criticisms there are some
people who will say Oh Kirk is just he's
a nineteenth-century man who's thrust
into the 20th century he's a romantic
what she was there is no question
question that Kurt is an idealistic
romantic he would have enjoyed walking
tours with Wordsworth or Coleridge
there's no question about that he could
have easily and he was a very eccentric
person we haven't talked about that John
but in just as eccentric as they come
but yes that that word conservatism
becomes the word it really brings in all
of these disparate schools
anti-communist SPRO liberal arts great
books people and here at Chicago people
like Mortimer J atler others st. John's
University in Annapolis and in Santa Fe
but it does bring together a lot of
people and one person who is absolutely
taken with this book strangely enough is
this pilot from Arizona Barry Goldwater
and that it's a catalyst for him well in
the conservative mind pretty much begins
with Edmund Burke and and his thought
talked a little bit about the importance
of Edmund Burke and she looked and
talked about some of the other people in
the book the the other litany of
conservative Saints if you will yeah it
is that's a great way of putting it
because the conservative mind really is
a hagiography it is very much looking at
roughly 29 people looking at their lives
and what they contribute they don't all
agree and that that's important for Kirk
that in the book these 29 characters
some we know well people like Edmund
Burke he's at least well-known to most
academics at the time people like Alexis
de Tocqueville but others you know we
are leave South Hall yeah with this
this obscure British figure who deals
with common lawns a lot of these people
we don't remember very well in America
he's laudatory of Irving Babbitt and
Paul evermore Harvard historian a French
and a Princeton historian of the
classics right I think they're great
guys but nobody picks up babbitt or more
or but there are some other names we
know very well absolutely
so TS Eliot yeah he ends the book with
TS Eliot and of course he and Elliot
become very good friends starting in
1953 and they shape each other's thought
profoundly and I don't think we could
have had a conservatism here or abroad
without Elliot really Elliot giving his
kind of sanction to Kirk and Elliot had
won his Nobel Prize and so forth but you
know to go back John certainly Burke is
important so Kirk he he bookmarks
he gives us bookends for the
conservative mind starting with Burke
and John Adams so the two great figures
of their day as he sees it
Edmund Burke in England John Adams here
and then he ends with TS Eliot he has
these twenty six figures in between
those two 29 overall Burke is important
and Burke is a great figure I argue and
I have the great privilege of teaching
American Founding founding of the
American Republic where I teach at
Hillsdale I get to teach that every two
years I absolutely love it but I always
make sure that as the students are
reading John Dickinson or Thomas
Jefferson we also do a good deal of
Burke part of that is because I love
Kirk and I like Burke as well but a huge
part of it is Burke was the leading
person in Parliament he put his life on
the line more than once he was actually
treasonous at defending American rights
and he did that for his whole career and
it wasn't just a political movement
Burke truly believed that the Americans
had inherited the very long tradition of
common-law trial by jury the right to be
innocent until proven guilty habeas
corpus a Burke believed that we were the
true Englishmen and that was Kirk's idea
as well so there's a Burkean sense
that's very important for our modern
conservatism but I think John it's
equally important to state Burke is not
unique he is one in a very long line of
thinkers
so even though Kirk starts his Berk book
with Burke Burke is the inheritor of
Socrates Plato and Aristotle he's the
inheritor of Zeno and Klee Anthony's and
all the greats through the Western
tradition Burke represents that so for
that idea to come forward that is Kirk's
understanding that we as Americans and I
would even you know for the audience
especially in those watching c-span look
at Ronald Reagan if you go back and look
at Ronald Reagan's speeches in 81 and 82
he'll talk about the greatness of
America but what he talks about so
importantly is America defending the
greatness of the West and he he like
Kirk
he draws that in now later I think
Reagan becomes a little more
nationalistic but in his earlier years
he's concerned with the Western
tradition and really the best of the
Western tradition and that's why Kirk
picks Berg as well and the conservative
mind obviously obviously set the table
set the table for for Kirk's career he
was a writer throughout his life helped
found the National Review where he was
along with William Buckley where he was
a columnist a syndicated newspaper
columnist widely read across the country
several other books important book on TS
Eliot among others a novelist you know
just a just a protein creative figure
and and if for nothing else he'd be
remembered for that despite the fact
that that early on he did not talk about
conservatism as a as a as a party as an
agenda as politics he did get very much
involved with with politics as you
alluded to with with Barry Goldwater's
candidacy in 1964 what what prompted
that shift and how did things play out
yeah that that's an awkward subject in a
lot of ways simply because Kirk really
goes against his own principles and I
think in many ways the Kirk I won't say
in many ways and every way I could find
Kirk really was a man of integrity and
I'm sure he had his faults and I've seen
you hide a temper and so forth but he
really did
try to live what he preached this was
not a guy who was he did make a lot of
money but he gave it all the way we
could talk about that that's maybe a
different story but he had argued as
early as 1953 and he takes this from one
of the great writers of the late 19th
century George Gissing he said politics
is for the quarter-inch and it's not the
nicest comment to make but he believed
that real change at least early on real
change came by writing books it came by
dealing with newspaper editors it came
by writing syndicated columns he was
truly a man of letters and that he
believed that a real intellectual
presence and a real change would take at
least 25 years we don't go into Congress
assuming that we can if we get this one
law passed everything will change
tomorrow
he very much had a long view he saw how
civilizations had risen how they had
fallen he knew that the Great's of Civ
Western civilization people again I know
I've mentioned them already a couple of
times but the three greats of Greek
society Socrates Plato and Aristotle
they had all come at the end of Greece
not during its heyday they were all
nostalgic writing about what they had
lost the same thing is true with Cicero
the same thing is true with Saint
Agustin they all come at the end of
their age and Kirk for calling his book
originally the conservative route he
thought we too were at the end of the
West and therefore our job would be kind
of like medieval monks we would
transcribe and preserve but then this
young senator who has a lot of charisma
and even though only about a third of
the population liked him of the American
population that third really really
liked him and Goldwater was by all
accounts and I'm not a Goldwater scholar
but it's hard to dislike him when he met
with people he was totally honest yet
people used to talk about that when
Goldwater and Nixon would meet donors
Goldwater would never ever ever placate
a donor yeah if it was GM and GM wanted
some kind of subsidy or tariff Goldwater
would say to their face no I would never
do that
and Nixon would say yeah I think we
could work something out it was it was a
difference I mean people would describe
Nixon as being like he was he was a
promotion he was the guy who was
promoting the boxing match and Goldwater
was the actual boxer you know and that I
think that's an interesting and I again
I'm no expert on Goldwater or on Nixon
but Goldwater I don't think any of us
would ever think he lied he was just a
guy whatever he thought he spoke I think
Kirk was pretty taken with that and he's
also he's a young man
here's Goldwater calling him from
Washington DC calling him in the costume
Michigan and saying you know my two
favorite authors are you and Friedrich
Hayek I need to know what do I need to
say to make this work how will I
convince people and I think a young Kirk
was pretty flattered by that I think he
was taken in by that and he became very
involved Goldwater called him all the
time they met at times and places like
Florida of course they with William F
Buckley strategized how do we kick out
the Birchers we don't want these people
on our side how do we kick out the
radical right none of these people
should be a part of legitimate
conservatism and that it was a good team
for a while but now the movement the
Goldwater movement I think went off in
different directions
and Kirk really didn't get involved in
politics much after 64 and he wasn't
good at it yeah he was good if you want
an honest politician Kirk's fantastic if
you want a winning politician Curt's not
that good
well because along the way obviously he
supported Reagan but yes but also
supported Democrat Eugene McCarthy's
running 76 yes Pat Buchanan later on and
yes he loved Norman Thomas the socialist
voted for Norman Thomas in 1944 I mean I
think he was much more concerned with
personality and who he thought was
honest you know there's obviously a lot
of names and influences that that that
Kirk enjoyed it is very enjoyable in
your book to to go to go down all of
those paths of all of these these
thinkers who influenced Kirk's thought
there's there's probably more ideas per
page in this book than a year's worth of
TED talks
it's it's absolutely fascinating
intellectual history
by the same token Russell Kirk as you
alluded to was an interesting character
he was not just a writer off in a room
somewhere
lots of eccentricities a little bit of a
prickly nature talk about talk about the
man himself and some of those
peculiarities he thinks John it's a
great question and I don't think you
could ever walk away from Russell Kirk
without knowing his personality he he
was bizarre
my favorite story my wife's favorite
story as well my favorite story about
Kirk a year before he gets married so he
doesn't get married he's a bachelor all
the way up until 1964 he marries just
about a month before he turns 46 marries
this beautiful woman Annette Kirk
brilliant she'd been a model in New York
extremely intelligent still lives in
Mecosta Michigan runs the Kirk Center
just a force of nature incredible person
and they were a great team but a year
before he gets married he'd always
travelled the world not as a young man
but once he went off and served in the
military he became enamored with
traveling his world traveler traveled
throughout North Africa travel
throughout South Africa throughout all
of Asia traveled throughout all of
Europe usually would just live on peanut
butter yeah he didn't mind poverty at
all he was always whatever he had that's
what he had money was only a means to an
end for Kirk that's another story but so
in 1963 he and a Hungarian scholar
decide that they're gonna spend the
summer now I can see maybe walking
across all of North Africa and the
winner but they decided to pick the
summer they walk all across North Africa
and everywhere Kirk goes because he's
Kirk he always carries with him a
portable typewriter is that thing is
everywhere in his letters I John had
never in I'm 48 in all my years of
researching I have never seen a body of
letters like what Kirk left the guy
never stopped writing he could do 120
words a minute he had a photographic
memory just amazing but so 1963 he walks
across the desert with torment Thomas
Molnar this Hungarian scholar and he
wears the whole time a three-piece tweed
suit across the Moroccan desert he
carries with him not only
his typewriter but he has this huge cane
that has a sword in it and you know the
TSA wouldn't allow this now obviously
usually carried a revolver wherever he
went
he's just an absolute eccentric and of
course Bedouin children yet they follow
him everywhere his bizarre character
walking across ends up in Europe after
this whole thing gets to an opera in
Italy I think he's in Florence if I
remember right and they're late he and
his friend they show up this opera after
this whole journey and he he wore an in
addition to wearing his three-piece suit
everywhere he had a a Count Dracula cape
but he had one for one of his horror
stories he'd gotten in the prize The
Count Dracula prize Ray Bradbury was one
of his good friends and he loved wearing
this high collared cape and so he shows
up the operas late the security guard
will not let them in at all there's no
way you know we're late doors not
opening
and so Kirk's friend says do not
understand this is Russell Kirk he is
the Duke of Mecosta the guard oh I
didn't realize he was from a Duchy it's
the cost is his tiny little 600 person
village in Michigan and they let him in
so this is crazy well in Mecosta small
town in in michigan has has was his home
yes and he rebuilt his home in a rather
grandiose manner yeah he this is the
other story about Kirk we don't forget
and frankly if any of you end up reading
the book and I hope that you do of
course but if you do I would ask you're
the one thing to take away that I think
is so brilliant about Kirk and I ended
the book with this because I thought
well they start with this no one will
believe it but Kirk did make millions of
dollars during his lifetime not only
from his books but especially from his
fiction he did very well with his
fiction and most people who know his
horror fiction he wrote these gothic
horror stories don't know he's also the
founder of post-war conservatism and
most people who read his conservatism
don't know he was also a fiction writer
but the thing that I think is most
impressive about him is when he died he
was basically broke he gave everything
away he and his wife used to drive into
Grand Rapids they would look for
homeless people pick them up anybody who
wanted to
from Cambodia Ethiopia anyone escaping
from communism or fascism they open
their houses their house to them and so
the daughters they had four daughters
they would wake up every morning they
never knew who would be at breakfast
with them because at times there were 18
Ethiopians or thirty Cambodians
Vietnamese all of these people one of my
colleagues where I teach at Hillsdale
one of my closest friends economist by
the name of Yvonne Punk Rasik he was
brought out of former Yugoslavia because
of Kirk and we don't often remember that
about these guys I mean Kirk truly lived
this in every way and one of the persons
and I think this is what you're alluding
to John one of the persons Kirk met was
an ex ex-con who was on parole from
upstate New York who happened to be
walking through Michigan in the late
1960 through Mecosta and his wife met
him it was a man named Clinton Wallace
Kirk thought this guy was fascinating
they invited him in for Sunday brunch
and they loved him and they invited him
to stay and he ended up living with them
he called the parole office in New York
said we'll take care of this guy Clinton
Wallace ends up living there on Ash
Wednesday of all days 1975 he
accidentally leaves the great to the
fireplace open and they burned down
Kirk's home and they have to rebuild it
after that and it's this beautiful
ornate Italianate structure there but
here's what I think is beautiful in st.
Michael's Cemetery which is just a few
miles from Acosta that was Kirk's parish
they bury Clinton Wallace he died around
1978 his tombstones right next to
Russell Kirk's but it's great it doesn't
say hobo doesn't say a homeless drifter
ex-felon it says Clinton Wallace Knight
KN IG HT Knight of the road and that's
that's Kirk he loved people he loves
stories of people he was very forgiving
but he also this guy was interesting so
Kirk liked and and Curtin was that
eccentric too he just wasn't on the
criminals it so let me ask you what
something that you might imagine Kirk
would think about what's going on these
days I don't mean to to put you in his
mind but but who better to ask than
somebody who's who
who's put together this biography what
what would he think about today's
political environment he'd be horrified
in every way he'd be horrified and I
think two things would have bothered him
immensely and he spent the last three
years of his life combating this he was
right or wrong he thought that George
Bush's foreign policy first George Bush
was just against everything that America
really stood for he was very worried
about the first Gulf War he saw this as
our first foray into serious Perman
American Empire he was he spent those
three years I don't think he was very
successful in fact he was really run out
of the conservative movement for his
views on this and he made some remarks
that were not very judicious but he was
very much against this he thought Bush
had betrayed the entire Reagan legacy
Kirk was fine with a large military he
just didn't think we should use it it
was one of those things you have a
military so you don't use it and he did
not believe in any form of overseas
expansion so he would be the idea that
we have troops now stationed in 150
countries out of a hundred
roughly hundred ninety six something
very different from what it would have
been in 1991 he would have been very
very upset about that he would not in
any way recognize the people that we
call whether we were using it
pejoratively or not neo-cons
he would have thought that their
ascendency he would not have predicted
that but he was very worried about the
possibility but he also and I think this
is maybe even more important and I don't
want to necessarily name names but the
idea that you would have radio shows
dedicated to conservatism as art not I'm
sorry let me rephrase that
not as art but as entertainment the fact
that you would be selling conservatism
as a radio show or a TV show his
conservatism what we're doing here John
where we're actually having a discussion
and you're letting me talk more cause
you're very gracious but what we're
doing here in taking thirty five forty
five minutes and actually thinking about
an idea that for Kurt was what we should
be doing he may have disagreed with say
macneil-lehrer but that was the proper
way of doing news now he was on the Eric
Sevareid show and in the early 1960s and
there
people like mine Rand who was just going
right at him just kind of sat back and
of course he very radically disagreed
with her strong brand of individualism
kind of his social Darwinism his his
brand was completely different it was
very charitable and he just let her talk
and then he just answered very calmly
and she was frustrated he he just he was
fine when he does that and he actually
got along really well but with Malcolm X
same kind of thing they just half our
discussion and I think that was
important for him sound bites
no that wasn't his sodid discussion
exchange of ideas good thing and in
closing here we wanted to open up the
the floor to any questions from the
audience for Professor burrs or if there
are any about Russell Kirk his thought
or or this book going once we've
answered all the questions what what one
last question will close in brief
Russell Kirk's legacy yes well John let
me I'll try and I'm sorry we aren't sure
I absolutely have one question it will
go to that thank you sir two questions
one is what was his reaction to what
happened in the sixties so much
conservativism today seems to come from
that and this is someone off the subject
but there's been along the news lately
about how conservative professors on
campus or somewhat hounded and afraid to
come out of the closet as conservatives
you have any comments on that thank you
for coming today yes thank you and thank
you for both of those questions Kirk
like most conservatives was confused by
the 1960s he spent his time he did
attack some radicalism on campuses but
he also was willing to debate and engage
and one of my favorite stories and this
is not something I go into in great
detail partly because we don't have a
lot of evidence but he was asked to
speak at the University of Michigan and
he was asked to speak by SDS as well as
the Black Panthers there and he was to
debate Tom Hayden and he got in front of
this crowd a crowd that was predisposed
to Tom Hayden it's a pretty radical
group but Kirk was without
question he was a gentleman and he
treated no matter who he was talking to
he treated people with with respect and
Tom Hayden came late Kirk because the
event had to get started and Hayden
hadn't shown up
they allowed Kirk to give a speech
waiting for Hayden Hayden came in from
the back of the room at least as the
story goes and Hayden came in and just
immediately started launching into Kirk
as a defender of corporate capitalism
and a person who was defending the
establishment and the story goes and
again I've not been able to verify all
this but even if it's not true I think
it says so much about what we remember
about Kirk and explains a lot there was
a young man african-american man in the
front row who was a very convinced Black
Panther and as soon as Hayden launched
into Kirk this guy stood up and just
started yelling at Hayden and said you
have no right to do this you didn't
listen to this man this man actually has
more respect for us than you're showing
now and by all accounts Kirk won the
debate because whatever he said he
treated everybody well and it wasn't a
show for him this was serious
conversation and I think it's really
important to note that Kirk in his life
whatever again modern conservatism has
become Kirk was always a defender of
people who would have been called
minorities in the 1950s always I
believed that the changes that were
happening in the 60s were necessary he
believed you from the very beginning
that he has an editorial I think 1963
and yes would not go over well with
libertarians are hardcore free-market
types he said he thought one of the
ugliest things that had developed in
American culture were road signs big
billboards and he actually has an
editorial in one of his newspaper
columns that all good citizens should
spend their time two facing billboards
because they don't do anything for the
beauty of America you know any road on a
necessity of good architecture inside as
well as out is a very interest to any
planet in his lifetime he planted
thousands upon thousands of trees
because he said it was his duty to make
up for the sins of his ancestors who had
raped the environment
that's not when we hear radio
personalities on in the media today who
were espousing conservatism it's not
generally what we hear as to your second
question sir I can't really answer that
I know a lot of my friends who are
conservative feel very oppressed in the
Academy I'm teaching at a small college
that's very open I have never
experienced that the last year I had the
great blessing of teaching at the
University of Colorado at Boulder had a
one-year position there I loved it yeah
I'm sure people thought I was weird but
I had nothing but good experiences so my
own know for what it's worth my
anecdotal evidence I have not seen that
but I certainly know my friends who are
conservative or libertarian do not feel
the way I do but it may be I've just
gotten lucky you know we have we have
come to the end of our time I wanted to
remind everybody the book is russell
kirk american conservative bradley burrs
were has been our guest here thank you
very much Sean one of my conversation
you and thank you everyone and everybody
enjoy the rest of lit Fest today thank
you so much and thank you for attending
today's program this book will be sold
just outside the door and your feedback
is important to us so please visit
printers roll it fest org and now
complete the post-event survey thanks so
much and have a fantastic day
what do you like
thank you
and this is book TV on c-span - and that
was Bradley bursar talking about his
book Russell Kirk American conservative
we'll be back with more from the
printers Road lick fest in about 10
minutes
up next author Sidney Blumenthal talking
about his book on Abraham Lincoln this
is book TV on since Benton
[Music]
at a university in the western world not
just the United States if you believe
that God created heaven and earth that
God is the source of thou shalt not
murder not just reason you are
considered a dummy and and that that
foolishness and that truly is foolish
because the deepest people I had ever
met
I've overwhelmingly had a god-centered
understanding of the world but that is
now taken as a given that if you believe
something like that you are
intellectually suspect so that's what's
happened when you hear somebody say I'm
spiritual but not religious I have done
hours of radio just on that subject
it is with all respect to people who say
it it is meaningless it means I
contemplate my navel in a sophisticated
manner that is the code word it doesn't
mean anything I'm spiritual but not
religious what does it mean if you have
no religion what do you have
spirituality what a spirituality mean
that you believe that that flowers are
beautiful that you believe that animals
are loving what does it mean it doesn't
mean anything I know to the individual
making it it means something but without
religion without a code religion gives
you a code religion gives you a set of
beliefs I don't care if you reject them
but at least you have to grapple with
them remember Israel which is the the
founding group of the Old Testament
means struggle with God and I take that
seriously as a believer I do struggle
with God when I see all the suffering in
this world the unjust suffering when
just thinking for a moment forgetting
the obvious of your neighbor had
pancreatic cancer at 32 but a whole
country called North Korea which is
which is a human concentration camp
the way people live there
and the the the hundred million of World
War two I mean if you know these things
bother me so I understand struggling
with God as a believer but I want the
Atheist to understand you have to
struggle with God too
it's not enough I was invited to the
great credit and they're great credit
the American atheist the biggest atheist
group in the u.s. far as I know they
invited me to their annual convention
which was to their credit and to debate
their head on God's existence at one
point I looked at the audience who were
completely by the way decent to me and
and I can't complain at all they were
just fine but I said two of them at one
moment would you raise your hand if you
have ever seen a child born or listened
to a buff partita or a Mozart symphony
or seen a van Gogh painting or seen a
sunset and said you know it's hard to
believe that just happened on its own
maybe there is a God not one hand went
up and then I looked at them and I said
you know if I were to ask any religious
audience have you ever seen a deformed
baby and doubted God raise your hand
everyone would have raised their hand we
believers struggle more than you
atheists do and you think your the
question he was where the questioning
was you can watch this and other
programs online at book tv.org the New
Boston Post recently put together a list
of the top ten conservative books to put
on a summer reading list the list starts
off with Pulitzer prize-winning
columnist
george will's the pursuit of happiness
and other sobering thoughts which is a
collection of essays written in 1978
William F Buckley Jr is next on the list
with an exploration of his Roman
Catholic faith in nearer my god the
Downing Street years by Margaret
Thatcher is third on the list and
discusses her time as the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom
in the way of the wasp Richard
Brookhiser examines the personality and
values of George HW Bush and his views
on public service and tradition the
autobiography the undocumented mark
Stein is fifth on the New Boston Post
list of suggested summer reading
followed by the closing of the American
mind which is alan blooms critique of
american culture
next on the list is former Oklahoma
Senator Tom Coburn's the debt bomb which
lays out his plan to make the government
more fiscally responsible Wall Street
Journal columnist Peggy Noonan's the
time of our lives is a collection of her
columns and comes in eighth on the list
finishing off the New Boston Post list
of suggested summer reading are Randy
Barnett's examination of the
Constitution and how it applies to
politics today and restoration another
book by George Will on term limits and a
functional democracy book TV has covered
many of these books over the years you
can watch them on our website book TV
org Carrie Goldstein what do you do at
Simon and Schuster I am the VP executive
director of publicity and a senior
editor and what does that mean that
means I run our publicity group and when
I'm not doing that I try and acquire
books all right well we wanted to talk
to you on book TV about some of the
books that are coming out this season
but tell us one book that you've been
working on as an editor as an editor
well I've just turned in a final edit on
Siri who's FETs next book which will
publish in December a woman looking at
men looking at women and series very
interesting most people know her as a
novelist she was a long listed for the
last Booker Prize for the blazing world
but she leads a double life and she
happens to be one of the most respected
thinkers and writers in the field of
neuro ethics and neuroscience and so the
new book is a triptych there's a section
on art criticism and ways of seeing and
gender bias a section of book length
section on
neuroscience and a final section on
psychology and philosophy with
Kierkegaard at its center and writ large
all three of them are basically a
response to the age-old Cartesian
mind-body question and of course Siri
who's FET is from Northfield Minnesota
went to st. Olaf College so what are
some of the books that Simon and
Schuster has coming out this fall well
we have a great list so I'll just focus
on a few in the in the minutes we have
together probably the biggest book we
have this fall or the most anticipated
would be Bruce Springsteen's born to run
a little musician out of freehold New
Jersey some people have heard of and
born to the run is his first book and
probably the thing that most people will
want to know now is that he spent seven
years writing the book even before he
thought about finding a publisher and he
started writing it after his performance
at the Super Bowl wrote the book on his
own in his free time and when the book
came into our hands it was done and it's
everything and more that a not only fans
of Bruce would want to read but anybody
who's interested in a cultural and
musical history of the nation in the
last thirty years forty years will find
it fascinating as well
is he going to go on tour for Simon &
Schuster well we're trying to sort that
out right now and there's no question
that we'd like to put him in front of
his audiences and I know the he'd very
much like to do it we haven't figured
out exactly where we'll go or what we'll
do but we expect to yes
what's another title coming out another
title coming out this fall that's worth
talking about would be rows of Brooks's
how everything became war roses of
fascinating character
who did work in the Pentagon jealous of
the daughter of Barbara Ehrenreich as an
aside and so she marries and the only
reason I mention that is because she
marries a sort of peacenik upbringing
with work in war and the government's
role and what the book is about is how
the lines have blurred between between
the civilised war and a civilized world
and the military world and so we're in
former times it was very clear what the
line between war and peace was now we
have our military all over the world
involved not just in engagements with
foreign armies or
or organisations of that kind but
working with Ebola in Liberia writing
code doing all sorts of things that we
never knew our military should or would
be involved in and it raises all sorts
of questions about how it impacts our
lives as citizens and so Rose has done a
really brilliant job in sort of
deconstructing the separation between
war and peace in the world today so
Kerrygold seen how many books - simon
and schuster published in the air new
new time then the numbers never the same
but it can average anywhere between 115
130 books a year that's a full year so I
don't have the exact number on next
season but let's call it 50 55 front
list titles a blend of business fiction
nonfiction and all different kinds of
books for different readers within those
categories one more title you want to
talk about one other time I'd love to
talk about is wolf boys by a writer
named Dan Slater the book grew out of an
article Dan wrote for The New Yorker
which itself grew out of a headline he'd
read in the New York Times about two
American boys who'd been arrested
because they had become two of the most
dangerous assassins in the Zeta cartel
in Mexico and so in this book Slater
tracks these two American boys who get
involved with the cartel and the Mexican
born DEA agent who came to the States
himself as an illegal who was on their
tail and in this cat-and-mouse
page-turning
narrative what he's really doing is
asking questions about the war on drugs
and on the border and there's a cop in
the book from Chicago at some point says
something like the border may as well be
right here and just a few weeks ago
there was a story about this Ohio family
that was slain and there are suspicions
that those murders may have been
committed by a cartel as well so whether
you're in favor or disinclined to
support greater border security for one
reason or another there's no question
that any security will only increase the
value of those drugs and therefore
increase
the murder rate here in our own country
so it's a very important issue for
everybody
Carrie goldstein of Simon & Schuster
by the way book TV did a tour of Simon &
Schuster a year or so back if you'd like
to watch that you can go to book tv.org
type in simon & schuster in our search
function you can watch the whole tour
and now live on book TV from the
printers roll it fest in Chicago author
Sidney Blumenthal talks about the life
and career of Abraham Lincoln
[Music]
welcome to the 32nd annual Chicago
Tribune printers roll it fests I want to
give a special thank you